لا يريد الأوكرانيون
المساهمة بأي شكل أو شكل
لإثارة الذعر ، فهم قلقون من أن السكان المحليين
هنا سيصابون بالتوتر إذا
رأوا أن الولايات المتحدة بدأت في إجلاء
بعض الأفراد غير الأساسيين وأفراد الأسرة
الذين يشعرون بالقلق  أن ذلك
يبرز أه صورة يحتمل أن يكون
هناك بالفعل عدوان روسي
متوقع وشيك ولكن أه بينما
الجميع ينتظر العملية الدبلوماسية
وتأمل
أن تؤتي ثمارها فلا شك في
أن الاستعدادات الحقيقية
تجري من جميع الجهات من أجل
لقد أعلن الناتو للتو عن احتمال نشوب صراع عسكري
أنه سيرسل
موارد إضافية بطائرات مقاتلة
لنشر قوات الناتو في أوروبا الشرقية
التي استقبلها
الكرملين بالفعل بلهجة سلبية تقول إن
هذا يزيد التوترات التي يثيرها
الكرملين أيضًا.  حول ما أسموه
هستيريا إعلامية واتهام
الأوكرانيين بتكوين أه عسكر
وعتاد  على الحدود
مع منطقة دونباس ، حيث
يتمركز هؤلاء الانفصاليون الموالون لروسيا ،
لن يكون مفاجئًا للكثيرين على
الرغم من أن الأوكرانيين بالطبع
يعززون وجودهم على طول
حدودهم هناك لأن هذا هو بالضبط
المكان الذي يخشى فيه الكثير من نوع ما
قد يحدث التوغل إذا وعندما يحدث ذلك ،
أعتقد أنه شعور من الناس لا يزالون
يأملون في أن الجهود الدبلوماسية قد
تؤتي ثمارها ولكن تستعد في هذه
الأثناء للأسوأ أيضًا